baby there ain't no mountain high enough
[Music]
I got Sorella on my team they're the
only group in the show they have an
amazing control I mean you've seen they
have amazing control over their
harmonics
[Music]
sister Trio Sorella could be crowned The
Voice season 23 Champions giving Chance
the Rapper his first win or maybe OG
coach Blake Shelton will take home his
10th and final win I'll do whatever it
takes from for my team to win the odds
seem to be in the country star's favor
he's the only coach with two finalists
left Grace West
[Music]
thank you
and Nueva
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm excited I mean both of these artists
I think either one of them could win the
thing I'll be happy for him if he does
but I'm obviously trying to win myself
for like my team yeah and don't count
Kelly Clarkson out either she could
bring home her fifth whip with Soulful
singer D Smooth representing team Kelly
in the finals
I'm about
[Music]
good tonight
oh yeah and don't forget Chance's fellow
season 23 newbie Niall Horan because
he's got 19 year old Gina miles still in
the running
[Music]
you know what she deserves to win it
like the girl is just so gifted she's 19
years old I think we're forgetting that
too and she sings like that it's just
insane so I have such a big controlled
tone at that age is just nuts going into
the finale chance thinks Blake's gonna
pull some strings to get one last win
I'm not worrying about Blake's sympathy
vote as much as I am like he's got like
some sort of weird control over the show
and he's like a producer or something so
if anything goes Haywire just know if
Blake did cheat for sure you know chance
says a lot of stuff that's just not true
and he's he's lacking in credibility in
in the truth Department
uh you know I don't I don't know uh I've
I'll do whatever it takes from for my
team to win so maybe there is some truth
to string pulling now win or lose Blake
is going out with the Bang finale Knight
and with some familiar faces he's set to
reunite with his Frenemy and former
voice coach Adam Levine who will perform
with Maroon 5 on the live result show I
think that's the only bad idea that the
producers have had you know because
everything else feels like exciting and
we're you know we're looking forward to
it as a as a team and a crew here that
work on the show and then they say
Adam's coming back and everybody's like
well you know can't be perfect I guess
you know but we made room for him
[Music]
foreign